- [Narrator] If you want
to buy this pair of Adidas,
you can use your credit card
or a buy now, pay later service.
The result seems similar.
You don't pay upfront, but with BNPL,
you can break that full
payment out into installments
usually with no interest.
Buy now, pay later firms
have boomed over the last three years
and companies like PayPal, Apple,
and credit cards themselves
are joining in on the hype.
But as some of the companies scale up
with their growing customer base,
they're struggling to turn a profit.
Here's how buy now, pay
later services compare
to credit cards and what it means
for the next time you're checking out.
- Everything today is pay-as-you-go.
- [Narrator] Dan Dolev is an
analyst who follows companies
like Affirm, Block and PayPal.
- Credit is becoming a pay-as-you-go thing
especially in very young
millennial demographics.
- [Narrator] Buy now, pay later
companies took off in the US
during the pandemic.
Affirm, the only BNPL
focused company that's public
in the US reported its
revenue more than doubled
over the last two years.
One of the main ways
these companies make money
is through merchant discount rates.
A fee the retailer pays
to the company on each buy
now, pay later purchase.
- Selling is better than not selling
and merchants are willing
to accept somewhat
of a discount in order to make the sale.
- [Narrator] The number of
retailers signed on to use Affirm
jumped from just 6,000 in
2020 to 235,000 in 2022.
Part of the reason
for its popularity is
that buy now, pay later
is more accessible than a credit card.
- BNPL is very attractive
to people who have credit difficulties.
- [Narrator] Todd Baker is a lecturer
at Columbia Law School
who's worked as an executive
in finance and teaches
about emerging FinTech.
- Other people do it just because
it seems like a good idea.
- [Narrator] Let's go back
to that cart with our Adidas.
with a credit card,
You need approval to use that credit
often well before you put
your shoes in the cart.
Companies like Affirm, Klarna and Afterpay
on the other hand, can approve on the spot
and make approvals purchase by purchase.
That's because of the different
ways they check your credit.
Credit card companies do a deep dive
into your credit history that
shows up on your credit score.
Buy now, pay later companies
typically perform a
less formal credit check
and look at additional data
like previous times
you've used their service.
BNPL can give more spending power
to people who may not have access
to credit or have credit built
up, but that can be an issue.
- There is a risk that credit
will be extended to you
in a situation where you're
not likely to be able to repay
and that's not good either
for the issuer of the
credit or for the consumer.
- [Narrator] Affirm's CEO Max Levchin
says the company accounts for this.
- We do have to say no
and tell our consumers
with love and compassion
you're overextending yourself.
Please don't buy this.
- [Narrator] Klarna says
it also takes measures
to make sure it only extends loans
to borrowers who can repay.
Both Klarna and Afterpay
restrict use of their services
if a borrower misses a payment.
Buy now, pay later lacks some
of the regulated safeguards
that credit cards have
for consumers in the US.
That's in part because they're not covered
by the Truth In Lending Act.
This is a law that requires
that lenders provide you all
of your loan information
upfront, no hidden costs.
It applies to loans that are paid for
in more than four installments.
Buy now, pay later falls just below that.
- The product was structured essentially
to avoid the application of
the Truth and Lending Act.
The beauty of BNPL for the retailers
that it's instantaneous
and the provision of
significant disclosure
before a particular transaction
would be very difficult.
- [Narrator] Affirm
says it provides a truth
and lending disclosure
for all credit extensions
and Klarna says it supports
additional regulation
of the sector.
The Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau also warns
that consumers could risk over extension
meaning they have more
debt than they can handle.
This could happen
because they could borrow
from multiple lenders at once
since BNPL platforms can't
see borrowing activity
on other platforms.
Customer defaults, when they happen,
can have an impact on company's costs.
So they have to balance
the risk of delinquencies
with approving enough
transactions to cover their costs.
- That's the key to a
successful buy now, pay later.
It's underwriting,
underwriting, underwriting.
- [Narrator] Klarna said that
its underwriting practices
have helped keep its
default rates below 1%,
but delinquencies aren't the only thing
that can undermine profits.
Shifting consumer habits
can cut down on transactions
and many buy now, pay later
programs rely on funding
that is sensitive to interest rates.
Since merchant fees make up
the bulk of their profit,
companies might have to
raise them to make up
for higher borrowing costs.
- If interest rates go up a
lot, then they're in trouble
because the cost of
money's gonna be too high
to more than offset with
the merchant discount rate.
- [Narrator] Affirm and Klarna
offer services beyond BNPL
and are continuing to
diversify their offerings
but they're also facing
increasing competition
from Apple, PayPal and credit
card installment plans.
Still, for some buy now, pay later CEOs
like Affirm's Levchin,
the competition is clear.
- The enemy or the competitor
is the credit cards,
not each other.
- [Narrator] Despite these challenges,
Delev thinks that buy now,
pay later is here to stay.
- And as they become bigger
and offer more services,
they will be able to gain scale
and increase profitability.
- [Narrator] But some buy now,
pay later firms like Afterpay
have been bought by larger companies.
- The fundamental
question has always been,
is BNPL a business
or is it just a product
for other providers
of financial services?
And I think the consensus
seems to be shifting
towards the idea that BNPL
as a standalone business is
not likely to be successful
in the competitive market.
(gentle music)